messaged it um after friday prayers and
i was with a friend in the car and he
was like really
happy about the hadith that the sheikh
and the sermon mentioned and um
subhan allah he said he said something
interesting so so the brother was really
happy about it he was like
yeah you know this hadith you know it
says this is this
i was so into it and i was like you know
bro um
how do you even know that's authentic
and he was like man the shirt said
you know the message you know the way
you think the imam
giving the sermon is gonna quote
something that's inauthentic
so i went back home and or to the dorms
i checked it out
and indeed it was inauthentic and
that kind of messed me up because i
became a lot more skeptical than i was
and that's how my journey started
[Music]
give my own experience with this cause
when my mom
had gotten surgery she got part of her
liver removed
she was out of commission for a year
and the entire time like i didn't do
anything for her
i was just basically hanging out with my
girlfriend
going to parties doing drugs drinking
spending time with friends basically
ducking her and my sister
was taking care of her the entire time
now my sister
didn't say anything but like after the
fact
years later i reflected on that myself
and i was like damn like that was really
rough
you know that was really rough for me to
do that to my own mother
i'd probably be questioned about that on
the day of judgment and like
that's me being a self-reflective person
being able to see that but like if my
sister would have said
what i had told you to say like i'm sure
at that moment in time it would have hit
salaam you are now tuned in to the t3m
podcast the village podcast in the game
you are joined with home base the usual
with a very special guest today
we got our brother fareed salaam alaikum
why are they coming i hope you're doing
well hope you guys are doing well
man you got that radio voice eh um
i don't think so but um i'm glad i'm
glad if that's the case
all right so uh just quick question man
right off the rip how did you
hear about us how did you find us or uh
if you if you found us uh any youtube
videos
what uh what stuck out man what was one
of the first things you saw well subhan
allah
um i i i can't recall
uh the thumbnail that stuck out but
oh yeah there's a there's a question
mark who's thumbnail question mark i
clicked on the video and
it was eben murrah on your channel i was
like what's going on here
um so i need to ask about that how do
you guys
get eben [ __ ] um okay and you don't
know even without personally right no no
i i got no idea what mora
is that's okay
[Laughter]
man i should be saying that so uh we
launched our our podcast two three
months ago
and we had this brother out here named
ibn time traveler he started putting
timestamps on all of our videos
just uh nice detailed time stamps from
episode two and onward
and we we got in touch with him and
we're like yo why are you why are you
giving a time stamps like
you know just out of out of good will
and yeah he seemed to be a good brother
he's 16 years old his name is muhammad
by the way and uh nice man
yeah he even offered uh you know let me
make your uh
thumbnails you started making these nice
clean thumbnails that you saw one of the
ones that
caught your attention and uh clearly we
we realized you know what if he's been
doing this much without being a part of
the team
we definitely should uh extend out and
join him to the team
and that's how we are now t3m but it's
the four of us
respect man that's that's really nice
that's really nice um i'm surprised that
uh
imam mura himself wasn't on i mean like
you know
you guys jumped immediately to ibn as
that was quite a surprise for me
so imam he's he's like a real celebrity
even
still he's still getting there he's
getting there
what's funny is uh before i i got down
that rabbit hole
of christian prince i didn't even know
there was
there's there's like a whole game right
right yeah i think there's like three or
four of them by the way
three or four yeah yep
man um even before before all this went
down and we got in touch with you
i found your channel and i started
watching it a few months ago
and initially i found your your profile
picture and it was just you
and i watched the video and it was your
profile picture
in the middle of the video and there was
no video there was no you it was just
audio yeah i was like okay this is this
is interesting um
uh and then i found another video and
then i finally found you talking and i
was like bro this guy talks
he's actually here it's not just an
audio thing and i was like yo that's
cool
and look where we are now we have you as
a guest
the reason why i did that was because um
sometimes
when i go like on refutation mode i just
crunch out videos
um in a short span of time like a video
per day a video every two days
sometimes two videos a day three videos
in a day like i really go on on that
mode and when i do that
i still feel like i don't feel like
recording video and editing it properly
i just do as fast as possible just get
the audio out there at least
something's out there so that's the
reason why i do that um
uh as long as information gets out
you know that's sufficient man before we
before we even go into some of your
highlights
uh i like the david woods co-host
reversed islam
i liked some of the videos you made on a
plus you know a plus made a video on uh
on angel right
yeah yeah yeah there was a time i think
he's run out of content
by the way yeah uh yeah so
he's he's just trying to target
converts he even did one on saturday a
few
weeks ago um trying to analyze
why people convert islam and here's the
thing i don't know if you guys are aware
but he has a major
inferiority complex um when someone
who's been brought up in the west
converts this down
that to him is something really strange
it
shakes his faith in atheism
um it's it's quite interesting it's
quite interesting
man speaking about faith i know a lot of
people
are tuning in they're regular
subscribers of yours
i know some of them might not know who
you are exactly so for the people that
don't
and aren't caught up to speed give us
the cliff notes for
your journey into islam you know whether
it be a little boring like oh
i you know kind of was born into it
whether it be more interesting like you
were born into it you kind of strayed
had to come to it on your own um but we
want to hear it man
um alhamdulillah i i grew up in uh
in a muslim family uh that wasn't too
religious at first
um but with time my mom slowly became
more and more religious
by the time i was um 16
she was taking very seriously and that
naturally rubbed off on me
um but i didn't care much about
knowledge
until i was around 20 years old
and that happened when uh
i i came to know this brother who was
very
very very knowledgeable extremely
knowledgeable even though he's kind of
um falling out with a religion
to a degree i'm not saying he left islam
but he's he changed his lifestyle
he started to uh and walk in the path
that's not the
best path and then he actually um
well i don't want to talk about the
guy's sins and what he did but he
basically stopped practicing
in the way a conservative muslim does
and
uh it was really interesting seeing a
guy with
you know dreadlocks and and
uh you know uh um really trendy
uh clothing and even though you know i i
saw him previously like in ethol
and very traditional conservative or not
conservative but like a very
traditional um arabic clothing and now
he's
like he looks completely different i
don't see anyone
who was dressed anyway uh close to the
way he was dressed
um the way he spoke and the way he did
everything in a very uh
uh different manner and at the same time
if you ask him a little
question he would answer you in the way
that he would answer you
before he changed and that
was like whoa to me that was uh
a shock and uh it was fascinating not
asking about
specific matters in the religion and he
would give me a very
um uh detailed answer
this scholar said this this caller said
that and i'd be like well i'm like no
one speaks like that especially
when they don't look like you um
so i i realize soon after
that it was reading and he everything he
did
he learned through reading i would make
a joke he'd break down my joke
and he would say by the way you know why
that's funny it's because you got the
timing right you got the delivery right
your voice notice your the shift in your
voice and
that all these things put together plus
these were you know and
he'd break it down like what the heck
you know what how are you analyzing my
joke
it's like oh i read it in the book um
guy became the lead singer in a band
uh because he learned how to sing
through
a book and
so to me when i realized this
um reading became
something of importance to me just
realizing the reading itself
can change who you are and can make you
grow so much
um and before that i couldn't care less
about reading i thought
i thought reading was something that
people did that
uh you know people that didn't watch
documentaries that
you know people don't enjoy watching you
know movies or documentaries you can
learn
everything through documentaries that's
what i thought once upon a time
so that guy like uh helped me wake up to
the benefits of reading and one day he
parked his car
next to the college dorms and me and a
friend
went up to him and he opened the trunk
and it was filled with books and he said
take whatever you want i'm done
i'm giving away my collection so i took
several volumes of the stuff that he had
and
uh i pretty much grew through
that and the more i read the more
uh interested i became in learning and
one question led to another and
alhamdulillah
you know i've i'm i still consider
myself like a very small student of
knowledge i don't consider myself
you know that knowledgeable but
alhamdulillah
i learned a thing or two in the past
you know 15 years
that's that's enriching man so i wanted
i had a i want to reverse engineer a
little bit go back into
what you mentioned about uh when you
went into reading
when exactly did you really get into
reading islamic
literature or you know going into hadith
and
stuff like that because you know a lot
of people
like reading that i've seen but it's not
really with islam
they love reading you know novels and
books and history
and uh i know a lot of other people they
they are muslim
but they don't realize that there's this
there's so much to read
but islam there's so much you know works
and you know books on medicine and
it's a radical man yeah so
it started for me around that same time
um
to be honest uh the first thing
that really like opened my eyes was uh
what was it it was
basically uh a very short uh book by ibn
tamiya in which he
speaks about the attributes of allah
and that to me was like a life changing
book because to me
i felt like i didn't know anything about
allah before
that and and finally through the
verses gathered in that book through the
narrations gathered in that book through
the explanations um i i
was using ebbinghauthay means
explanation i for the first time i was
like oh my god
you know i i'm i'm actually learning
about my creator
um so that was that was the first book
that like
totally blew my mind and i don't think
there's anything that blew my mind as
much ever since
then subhanallah yeah the reason
um it really stood out for me now maybe
someone who's watching this
is thinking why not the quran
the quran is something that me as a born
muslim grew up with
and because i'm so attached to it
or because it's right there i couldn't
experience it in the way
a convert to islam experiences the quran
so i mean it is quite unfortunate um
and it's the same it's the same with
with with all arabs all arabs can't
uh you know enjoy the quran in the same
way that the first generation of muslims
enjoyed the quran
um so yeah that book that explained the
attributes of allah
that was the first thing that was the
first thing that
really grabbed me and then that's how i
got into that
more or less man feel free to jump in
whenever you want
when was this book written by the way
um seven centuries ago
around that much it was it's quite short
by the way it's very very short
um the explanation is quite modern
um it was the whole book is basically
something that was
written from like hassler to major
time or something is it's extremely it's
extremely simple
short but it it had an impact on me
law would you say that reading about
allah's attributes or
getting a better understanding of allah
brought you closer to islam better than
anything else would because a lot of the
time i've been told that we should start
with
with learning about allah
oh definitely definitely and the reason
is
because some some
schools of thought um
the the relationship between they they
view the relationship between man
and and creator to be a very
um impersonal
one a very uh cold one in the sense that
they misinterpret some attributes so for
example
um the fact like
here's there's a very very basic example
um allah
gets angry okay it's extremely simple
and and you ask any muslim in the street
there's a luggage of course you know a
lot obviously gets angry
but you have schools of thought that
don't believe that they say no
anger is something that allah doesn't
is free of because anger is something
that
that man can only feel or or is only
something that
the creation can have and not the
creator even though we have
clear verses in the quran that speak
about
the anger of allah so things like that
made me realize that you know there's
there's
there's a i mean not that specifically
i'm not speaking about that specific
attribute
but that's just like a very simple
attribute that uh
i'm sure everyone can relate with um so
some schools would interpret
anger to mean um uh
wanting uh punishment
you know they would they would explain
it as wanting punishment
or wanting um yeah you know like wanting
to punish
a strange interpretation but yeah that's
that's what it is
so that makes sense that doesn't make a
lot of sense
the first thing that popped in my head
was like the whole like ashrae versus
authority kind of
discussion where do you interpret this
literally or is it
you know for us to understand but it
actually means that so on and so forth
um so jessica welcome bro
yeah have you felt that have you noticed
that when uh you looked into those
things
um attributes in general or like ashrae
vs authority kind of
uh either either question you feel like
answering
um
one thing was i i heard hamza zorces
uh in a video he was um countering
something william lane craig said
about uh being all loving and all that
and he was trying to criticize
allah's love in the quran and islam
and hamza zoroasis was like you know it
doesn't make sense for god to be
all loving because then he loves
everything and it's opposite and that's
just that doesn't make sense right
um and that really resonated with me and
he talked about
um how allah is like which is like a
giving type of love
uh but allah says um
allah right allah does not love
the the disbelievers and allah
loves you know those who do good and so
on and so forth and that type of love is
just
general love so in that case i'm like if
you interpret that as all loving you
fall into the same problem
so yeah perhaps it's not all loving it's
most loving as most people interpret it
so that was the the closest experience i
said um
i i'd say i had um and i was asked a lot
of times in my live streams about
authoring ashrae and all that
and generally i stay away from the topic
because i don't know too too much
but um i never interpreted allah's
attributes to be literal
but i understand some people do uh so
that i'm still studying myself if you
want to comment on that feel free to
i'm going to avoid the topic just to be
safe for now
yeah it's all good it's all good um
uh there's so much to say there's so
much to say on the subject
and then it's something i recommend all
muslims to read into
um you know like there are some very
basic
um ideas and concepts like that one
specific one
about last part getting angry it's
something i think that everyone can
relate to some of the other
attributes i understand
i understand why there is a difference
of opinion
between hey muslims in general in
regards to them
um yeah that's that's a lengthy topic i
guess
yeah it is inshallah another we'll have
you on for another podcast we'll be
talking about that inshallah
so um alongside people's you know um
confusion when it comes to islam and all
that a lot of the time you find
confusion with a hadith right and you
talk a lot about this on ishmael shalom
may love bless you and reward you
because it actually has helped me and
many people alhamdulillah all the time
i get people commenting on my lives or
my in my comments check out for it
responds and i'm like yeah
i already watch him and all this stuff's
kind of lost
so
okay for anyone who wants to read a
hadith is there any suggestions you have
because for a layman to even read sahih
bukhari
yeah they have access to it yeah but
that doesn't mean they can understand it
properly in its context and all that
i have no issues okay i i don't mind if
they go for it i'm
i'm not i don't think that uh the lay
person shouldn't read it or that the
only
uh benefit from reading it is baraka
i believe that many of the hadith are
very clear
to anyone and and you don't need to be a
student of knowledge in order to
understand uh much of what's in there
if you struggle definitely go to a
shaykh if you struggle go find the
commentary
there's no harm in doing that but
i'm against the idea of um
you know this is above our level let's
not read this because i mean
why not extend that to the quran right
there are some i mean the hadith usually
are
clearer in in its text
than some of the quran so are we going
to like avoid
reading the quran as well i got no
issues reading a hadith and
i but like i always use this my favorite
example is
i don't know if you guys have seen me
use this because i use an abuse this
example the prophet saws
ate chicken i don't know you guys see me
bring that up i bring that up like all
the time
i actually haven't yeah okay anyone
what do you guys think about that what
do you guys think about um
that report about the significance of
that report any thought that he ate
chicken
yep man probably enjoy some good chicken
bro
so you don't need much you don't need
much commentary you don't need an
explanation you don't need to return to
the books of the
scholars in order to understand that
when the report says he ate chicken
it means that he literally ate chicken
um
the significance of that is chicken
wasn't
that popular in hijaz you know people
ate lamb people ate camel
chicken was way down on the list so
that's pretty much it you know so that's
why that report was recorded
and again it doesn't need any commentary
you just read the report it's it's
actually like one line
the report's one line prophet peace be
upon him ate chicken
you know so i i joke and i'm like when
people will say you know
it's hard to learn hadith you know we
can't we don't have access to hadith we
need
for every single thing we need
commentaries for everything i say uh
here's a hadith please explain it for me
i need a bit hijab to explain and i
ain't no way to explain it think all
these are not to explain
this one line the prophet ate chicken
so oh yeah someone cook them like
the most ridiculous piece of chicken in
this world
he was like yo this is good this is good
alhamdulillah
um so would you
would you apply that same line of
thinking to like um
to other books about hadith that may
have a weaker hadith in them
okay that's a better question i think
that's a good question
um a lot of books of hadith
have hadith ratings and i think
i think if we jump into that it helps us
learn
more it helps us learn faster um
i you see there there's always the
question that arises is
what if i read the hadith and
you know i i apply this teaching
um and there's an issue with my
understanding
right or or what if i follow this
specific hadith and this specific hadith
is
weak
fell into this um understood
specific reports incorrectly um
accepted reports that are weak and they
thought that they were authentic
so for everyone for everyone it's a
learning process for everyone it's a
struggle
and as long as we do
as as as long as we try as hard as we
can
as long as our intentions are sincere uh
as long as we're not following our
desires and we're trying to
follow um the religion uh to the dot
then i don't believe there's a harm in
doing that
so that's my take at least
yeah that's that's a beautiful response
because for people like myself as
fayed says um what is it
paralysis by analysis something like
that over analyze and become paralyzed
yeah
i i tend to do that a lot so when it
comes to something as crucial as you
know your dean you're human you're islam
um especially when you have people out
there uh like like cp and
uh david wood and these people that take
these i had purposely out of context and
it's like well that's so funny just uh
watching a david wood video where he
takes like a small hadith and in between
the line
he adds his own commentary into it like
she's like
all of a sudden subhan allah um coming
out there and being like
he said this because of that and then
this and then it's like
where is that in the report where it's
not even just hadith he does that with
the quran too
like uh look at this this chapter this
verse allah says
uh man was made of this clay then he
says mud
then he says blood and he's like look at
all these contradictions
he's like come on bro we can give you
the facts but you still
you're still not gonna take it and i
think this is a wonderful time for uh
to answer my question on
what is what is all this even about
because there's people following along
saying weak hadith
strong hadi what is what does that even
mean there's also other people saying
what are a hadith right so let's get
into that
okay um so so i started learning about
hadith when i was around 22 years old
and it was something that
i just wanted to get out of the way um i
i was trying to get into all sorts of uh
any islamic
knowledge sonic sciences and um i was
told that hadith sciences is the driest
science and i said okay cool i'm just
gonna you know get into the dry science
um spend a few weeks on that a few
months on that i'm just gonna toss it
aside
and i'm gonna stop uh with you know
after when i'm done with that
and i just continue to read about it and
uh continue to love it um
subhanallah uh i i never saw as
something that was dry
um and the question that led me
into hadith sciences is a very direct
question which is
why do i believe in what i believe in
and
it's the exact same question you asked
duchy you said how do i know
this is authentic and how do i know this
is weak and what's up with that
and just the the question of um
attribution
and and why the scholars believe in what
they believe in in regards to narrations
um it set me on a journey a journey in
discovery of truth and
the reliability of these reports and
alhamdulillah i was
very satisfied i was very satisfied um
i'm quite curious about how you guys
felt and and how you guys
first uh
came across that came across the
concepts of
authentic and weak narrations before i
carry on
geez i got so many questions
well first off what do you mean by dry
science
okay so so for example quranic sciences
or especially
the quran itself it's eloquent
it's eloquent speech it has uh you know
historical narratives with um
with morals um
it has uh verses that uh
um how can i say this
that uh make your emotions um
flare your emotions um you can you can
it can fill you with hope uh it can
fill you with with um
with faith uh i'm sure all of you guys
have experienced that that it's
uh it's um it's a work like no other
however um you know with a hadith
i'm speaking about hadith sciences
themselves but not
the actual uh narrations right because
the actual narrations you
you also have um a lot of reports that
will bring you happiness and bring you
sadness and will
make you laugh and will make you cry but
the science is itself
determining what's authentic and what's
inauthentic
it's dry it's like math to a degree
i i hope that kind of answers that so
how would
how would they differentiate between
uh this one's authentic and this one's
not authentic
okay um be before even getting into that
i was i i
because i asked you guys first yeah you
did my best
so many questions you you wanted to know
what how we can
you know how you guys can
i want to know how you guys came across
the concept
uh because you know one would uh you
know one who who doesn't really think
about it
too deeply would perhaps assume that
everything recorded in islamic history
is probably authentic
i mean that's how you know one would uh
i don't know
no you hit the nail on the you heard the
nail on the head when i when i first
figured out the concept of inauthentic i
was like
bro what do you mean like there's people
because people
could not speak the truth about this or
about that
or about anything and it hit me with
first thing was confusion because i hate
confusion
anytime i came to islam there was no
confusion
that was that is one thing i loved about
islam there was no contradiction there
was nothing
even things that i i preconceived as a
contradiction
or as something to shake my faith it
wasn't long before i found the video
or an explanation or a commentary to
just clear me out and send me straight
when i first figured out that some
hadith could be very
complex or not you know authentic
hundred percent or it's not great sahih
or you know i was like i was like okay
this this adds something now because now
i could read it it doesn't mean it's not
authentic but it doesn't not mean that
and it's kind of this gray area for me
at least in the past
and then i i went into this uh you know
the major books of atheist um kind of
just
go into those not really if it's
authentic look at the grading
uh that was just me but uh what about
you ron
a lot for me i can't remember a time
where i was like oh really some things
are inauthentic like as far back as i
can remember
it's just somewhere some hadith were
authentic some weren't
some were weak some were like you know
indisputable
and i don't know because i started
practicing uh back when i was like 16
17. so it was like three four years ago
and i immediately what i did like how i
came to islam was like through a youtube
video
like i was always muslim but i wasn't
really practicing and then i saw this
youtube video
and then i was like subhanallah you know
that's that's amazing that's cool let me
get into this and i started researching
and looking things up and
listening to speakers corners guys and
all that so i was already like watching
the debates as they happen so as soon as
it comes up that this hadith is not
authentic
i was still learning so the concept was
there from the very beginning with me
so i don't think i really had a chance
to be like wait there's authentic and
authentic it always kind of made sense
some reports you know are by these men
and some of them are
weak in memory or they're liars so on
and so forth so it was never really a
challenge for myself but um on hill
ask your questions man geez no hold up
first
let me uh say i'm sorry for
cutting you off and starting to ask all
these questions man because
i just got a little emotional there man
but it's all good bro it's all good
to answer your question um i don't
really think i have an answer
i think like the best thing that i could
say is um
kind of to be expected you know like
sometimes people remember things
correctly sometimes not
i mean that's the best that i can say
because i haven't delved into it as much
as you guys have
okay so so in regards to what happened
with me
um i honestly can't recall
how it started off and how i came to
realize that there are an issue with a
lot of reports
um i do recall
having this this
skepticism um when when i was again
around 20
and i left the
the the
um after friday prayers and i was with a
friend in the car
and he was like really happy about the
hadith that
the sheikh and the sermon mentioned
and um subhan allah he said
he said something interesting so so the
brother was really happy about it and he
was like
yeah you know this hadith you know it
says this is this
i was so into it and i was like you know
bro um
how do you even know that's authentic
and he was like man the shirt said
you know the message you know the way
you think the imam
giving the sermon is gonna quote
something that's inauthentic
so i went back home and or to the dorms
i checked it out
and indeed it was inauthentic and
that kind of messed me up because i
became a lot more skeptical than i was
um and that's how my journey started
but it's it's as you said and how you
have people that
um naturally forgot um and you had
people that were uh naturally better in
in
the way they remembered things um
and that's the simple version uh behind
it you had people who fabricated reports
and you had people who um
they would i mean there are so many
reasons for a narration to be weak
um a narration can be weak due to
disconnection
um and the narration can be weak due to
the narrators themselves
so and and they technically fall
technically both
fall under the same issue of the
narrators themselves
because i mean if if a report is
disconnected if a person for example
came after the prophet peace be upon him
by 200 years
or 300 years or whatever and he's he's
narrating from him
without mentioning his sores then that
source in the middle
i mean that's bound to be someone right
or
usually um and if that's the case if we
don't know who that person is
we can't accept that we we don't rely on
anonymous narrators um there's so much
to say guys you guys need to give me
something more to go on
because
like i said i i could give you a
lightning round real quick
let's go for it all right so
first off are all hadiths
created after the prophet peace be upon
him his life
okay you need to define they mean by
creating so like what were they all
did they all come about like 100 years
after
200 years 300 years or were there some
that were
created is the word i wanna i want to
look
deeper into you said they were cr okay
written down
big big big difference right so uh
written down a lot were written down in
his lifetime
a lot were written down after um
you know could be a few decades it could
be a century it could be
10 centuries after it could be today
someone comes up with a hadith today and
writes it down for the first time
right but naturally naturally um
every authentic hadith uh is going to be
something that was written
quite early i mean that's just the
nature of things right if
if people believe that the prophet peace
be upon him said this is naturally
written down early
next question the lightning round or is
that yeah yeah we i got it oh bro i got
more please go for it go for it
okay so how is a
thief pretty much declared authentic
and authentic okay uh man
even that one's too too too uh wide
um okay so authenticity is basically
a report that is connected that has
reliable narrators that has no hidden
defects
um so uh that has no
irregularities um those are like the
basics
of an authentic hadith if all the
narrators in the reports
um have uh have narrated it from from
their contemporaries not from people
that were
you know uh that died before they were
born for example
um people that lived in their vicinity
um and then they narrated from them
and that chain goes all the way up to
the prophet peace be upon him
and the narrators of that hadith
are considered to be reliable by the
scholars of hadith
then by that alone
you can assume the authenticity of a
hadith
what what makes it what makes us
more reassured is if we have multiple
paths
for that uh one specific report
um so usually usually you would have
reports that
you know have one or two or three paths
however there are
other reports that go up to
like i think i think the the most
widespread hadith
those whoever lies about me um then he
shall uh basically uh uh
be seated in hellfire something along
those lines and that hadith is like
narrated by 70
companions or something like that 70
eyewitnesses
um that's quite a large number uh but
yeah usually it's it's
uh much smaller than that um
but here's the thing i mean if if you
hear of a hadith
that's collected for example and
narrated by
narrators in medina um and then you have
another hadith that says
uh the same thing but it's narrated by
narrators in iraq
or in the sham damascus
then the likelihood of that report being
authentic is quite high
[Music]
so and please don't take any disrespect
because
go for it just this is just my mind i'm
curious bro
yeah yeah so some of them i guess
you know we could see some clear
authenticity just because
like it was legitimate like they were
the actual companions and stuff like
that i said it but
correct me if i'm wrong the hadith is
pretty much like he said she said type
of deal
and it isn't that leaving too much room
for uh error because as humans we are
imperfect
and yeah i mean you say something now
and i guarantee you in 20 years i'll
probably misconstrue what you said
right right you know like my my mom and
dad used to tell me things when i was a
kid
i can't remember it a hundred percent of
course
of course of course no doubt no doubt
and i completely agree with you
um there are a few things that we need
to keep in mind though
um firstly uh
i don't i don't think that we usually
usually usually
we don't care as much
uh about what we heard from our parents
when we were kids
um in the same way that the companions
of the prophet peace be upon him cared
about what he said
right um to them religion was everything
to them islam was everything
to them preserving this information
them being linked to someone that was
connected to the heavens
was something so
again you had a lot of them writing down
reports
um but even those that didn't even those
that didn't
uh they you know they would practice
what they heard they would implement
what they heard and
once again what are the odds of
two different people from two different
locations
um who heard the same thing what are the
odds of
them making the same mistake
yeah you know i feel that but that still
doesn't
take away the fact that we are still
prone to error and
you know i could i could say something
right let's say i say something and
all three of you pretty much lock it in
yeah so far you know so and so you lock
it in
i pass away yeah if someone were to come
to you guys
and you guys were to agree on one thing
that's like oh this is what ang has said
like that
still it doesn't give you a hundred
percent the answer as to what i said
like i could have said it
slightly different you see what i'm
saying
i agree um but here's a question how
many people would you
need in order to be completely convinced
that that's how it was said exactly
just need the one person that said
sure but unfortunately he's passed away
right
no i know i'm just saying like of course
that's what like my mind is trying to
wrap it right now
right right right right so he's passed
passed away
he's passed away um and to you so so if
if one person said it
if one person said it what's the
percentage that you would give
that person for for being correct let's
let's give it a number
50 maybe more 60
17. probably
nothing but that's me that's me i've
always gone to like
straight there and again i understand
like i'm not discrediting anything i'm
not talking bad i'm just saying
like it's a thought exercise it's a
thought exercise
what if it was two people
doesn't change it okay so so two people
narrating one thing from a person um
you believe that there's a high
possibility of both of them
um coincidentally
getting the same thing incorrect
it's not that i'm saying that they're
gonna get incorrect it's not that i'm
like questioning them it's just that
for me i've always been persons like
okay i need to go
to the source like people used to tell
me about the kudan when i was
younger and it's not so i came to the
source that like
i saw it for what it was right like
we had all these people in the west
where i live i don't know what you did
brother what are you doing
i'm in the middle east okay beautiful
beautiful
so um in the west you have this huge
narrative
that uh islam is for terrorists
the islam is uh this terrible religion
and all this stuff
right you have all these people saying
and it's like even all these people
saying it were telling me
one thing so if i were to say i will the
authenticity of what is being said
because all these people
are saying it must be increased by so
and so percentage
then that means i would completely
believe authentically that ah
islam is terrible but there was still
that part inside of me i was like you
know what
i have to see it for myself i have to go
to the source
and once i went to the source i saw a
hold up
it was completely different than what
all these people were saying it was
okay do you see what i'm saying like i'm
different
um i'm curious to see if rami or if i
have a response to that
before i share my thoughts i'm gonna put
you guys on the spot you guys have been
picking on me all day
all right off the rip i'm just i'm just
giving my two cents lightning round
there's a hidden agenda and and this is
not
not something new to us but i'm sure ana
knows about
uh why would the companions of the
rasulullah
lie or fabricate things was it about
lying antelope was it about lying or was
it about the possibility
possibility of mistake like i said i'm
not claiming them that they're lying
i don't question them but i do
understand that we as humans are subject
to error
yep go for it man come on
romney you got anything yeah i have i
have two things i want to say very
quickly so firstly
this is not a direct analogy but it's
similar and i'm curious to know your
answer on this honestly
if you're driving on the freeway and you
hear on the radio
that a kilometer ahead of you on the
freeway a few kilometers you had on that
same freeway
or miles for you and you americans on
the freeway right there's an accident
are you going to get off the freeway or
are you going to say let me go see if
there's actually an accident
and find out for myself there's a
possibility that
yeah that's a very good analogy but
knowing myself i i'd probably keep going
i probably wouldn't
have gotten off the highway okay at
least you're consistent that's fair
so yeah from from what i've learned
about uh
is that a person's ability
intellectually to memorize and
not to falter in their memory is
actually taking it taken into account
and people narrators are reported to
have weak memory and if they have
weak memory and they're in a chain of
narration uh that would have
that could affect the uh authenticity of
the narration
and and brother fred if i say anything
feel free to you know
confirm it or not all right
so that's taking into account as well so
it's not
on such a superficial level where it's
just like it's just he said she said
it's
he told this person but that person has
a weak memory can we really trust them
let's scrap that versus this person told
their son
and they're both strong in memory
practicing they don't lie
they haven't harmed anyone like it's a
whole list of things
uh and these like these arabs are not
like us right the people who live there
they memorize like generations before
them their ancestors their names their
lineage all this stuff
and they didn't have like notepads you
know to write things down
on their phone they had to memorize
things when they did uh well i mean they
would make contracts for business and
all that but generally they would have
to memorize things they had better
memory
so to believe that these people are as
capable of faltering
um especially when people take into
account problems with memorization and
all that
um it's it's not the same as today and i
understand your skepticism
but it you just have to ask how much
that skepticism is based in reality
and are you being overly skeptical
that's that's my two cents
well bro even if the person has the
greatest memory
they're still human they're imperfect
there is
still subject to it again i'm not
questioning the person i'm not
questioning the authenticity as an
individual i'm not questioning the
memory i'm not questioning any of that
it's just
it is what it is bro like yeah sometimes
i might have the most perfect memory
in this world and even when i think i
have the most perfect memory and i'm
recalling something
i'm an error yeah okay okay
so so i i'd like to respond to the first
point
if you guys don't mind uh about the the
you know islam and terrorism um so you
mentioned that so many people said
that and and that
is equivalent to a lot of people
narrating a specific hadith
um the issue with that analogy
is that um when you have a lot of people
saying islam is terrorism
that's an understanding that's an
understanding of the nature of a
religion
it's not people reporting a specific
fact
we need to differentiate between the two
um
if you had if you you walked into a room
and you had two people share a theory
about life
that's very different than you know
walking into a room and
two people saying oh you just missed
um you know the doctor that was in here
there was a doctor that was in here and
he just left
right or or whatever they narrate or
whatever they'd mention regards to
uh an event that they both witnessed
um so so there's a major difference
between
the both things between understanding
and reporting
of a fact or reporting a statement
um i hope you can yeah yeah that's
that's fair enough yeah that's fair
enough okay so you're you're
uh you walk out of home one day and
let's stick with the freeway thing right
mm-hmm um i i like buds
um or or something similar right yeah
there's a car accident
you walk out of home and and a friend
tells you that
there is a car accident that occurred a
mile away
and they saw it right there's a
possibility
that it's a mistake um you continue
you continue walking and someone you see
someone else
and you ask them is there a car accident
that occurred
they say yes and i saw it as well the
likelihood of
both of them being mistaken is quite low
right
in the in this example yes yes
so let's let's make it a bit harder
let's stick with
statements um if one specific narrator
said i saw the prophet peace be upon him
eat chicken
and then you had another narrator who
said who also agreed you said i saw the
prophet peace be upon him eat chicken
the likelihood that he ate chicken
should be quite high mm-hmm
i hope now let me let me add something i
i did like that i do like that
yeah you got me over here thinking about
chicken i'm probably gonna eat some
chicken after this i don't know about
y'all
but um that's something that happened
right then then yes or no not
necessarily or not
but very very like not
100 years of course not 200 years 300
years
i agree i agree so
say that same example but with the 100
year difference
between the occurrence and then
okay that's where it can rise like i
agree
i agree i agree i agree um and and
how it works is uh
the people who narrated it again it's
not just
um it's not being narrated something
narrated out of a bubble
um but the people who came um
even 150 years after so
one of the early books of hadith is
malik and there are
a decent number of reports in which
between him
and the prophet peace be upon him just
two people um
it's not you know 10 people along the
way it's just two people
and once again a lot of the things that
he would narrate
are narrated by multiple
companions that narrate the exact same
thing
um but uh here's here's why i want to go
back to the previous question
um if you had
and i want to focus on direct witnesses
first of all before even moving to
later sources if if we had
because i want to know for each of you
guys um
the question of certainty when it comes
to
narrating an event or narrating a report
how many
people do you need in order to be
certain that someone said something
how many people do you need in order
how many eyewitnesses do you need in
order to be certain
of a specific statement that was said by
someone who
is not available for me personally i
would say
depending on the reliability it could be
as low as one
because if i if they've never once
missed told or misrecalled something
and they've always been on 10 in terms
of accuracy
i would be inclined to just go based on
one person but if it's like
i don't really know them right i don't
know how
reliable they are how accurate they are
it would it would feel better to have
more than
less of course of course
but i'm curious about the question of
certainty these are people that you
perhaps you don't know too well
how many would you need to be certain
how many random people
um that you'd meet you'd need
to be certain of their attribution of
something five
five okay somehow
no number will give me certain to be
honest
it really depends like it's just like
they're narrating something somebody
said
yeah uh if it's just something someone
said then maybe
it depends on who it is and what they
said but i think something like
10 would be enough but if that's a big
event
ten is certainty yeah yeah
it's not that i have yeah well um
um 10 random people who have no
connection with each other all telling
me the same thing
i would believe with full certainty at
that point okay not how about nine
how like what's the percentage you'd
give nine people
i mean i feel like mathematically would
follow would be ninety percent
oh ninety percent that's that's quite
that's quite uh
low for for nine people
i i might have misunderstood higher than
my percentage boy
[Laughter]
okay so the way i look at it the way i
look at it is um
if it's one person um
you know i usually i like to believe
that usually people that report things
usually get things right
i'd like to believe that um
i would i would perhaps give it a 70 or
something
right um if it of course it depends on
what's being reported right if it's
if it's a car accident that happened
five minutes ago the the
percentage of that occurring is higher
than someone reporting um
a story they heard from their
grandfather 20 years ago right
however if it was two people
two grandchildren that reported
something from that they heard from
their
grandfather 20 years ago um
i i would i would actually lean towards
a high number um something like 90.
uh because what are the odds of both of
them
making the same mistake okay
uh and by the way it's very important
that they're not influencing each other
it's very important that they're not
influencing each other and that means
that's something that we need to
uh you know be aware of um
what if it was three people the odds of
three people
making the same mistake in what they're
narrating
something that occurred 20 years ago
it's really really
slim um to me i think
i think any three or four
is is well let's say four is absolutely
certain
i cannot see i cannot see four people
making the same mistake and attributing
a statement to someone
it doesn't matter if they said it 20
years ago or 30
or 40. what are the odds they all made
the same exact mistake
it's just too too i just can't see it
happening
um now here's the thing when it comes to
religion
uh even though there is a possibility
that four people made a mistake
um we still have to follow that ruling
in the same way that if four people
testify that they saw an act of adultery
the judge applies that ruling even
though there is a possibility that there
was a mistake
and if we were hyper skeptical
and if we didn't apply
[Music]
testimonies because there was always a
fraction of
doubt then we wouldn't be able to
function
we wouldn't be able to function as
people wouldn't be able to function
societies
we wouldn't be able to function in
courts of law because there is always a
very small percentage of a possibility
of a mistake
and even even during the time of the
prophet peace be upon him
um he would he would send
like a single person to
let people know of his rulings um even
though there is a possibility of that
person
making a mistake he wouldn't need to
send um
10 people according to rami you know or
or
uh if
yeah so um sometimes one person was
sufficient
depending on what was supposed to be
shared what the message was
um and and the other there are many
factors
but in general in general uh the idea
that i'm trying to get across
is the likelihood of multiple people
making the same mistake
um is is quite low
especially if we add into that
multiple factors like the fact that
um many reports were written down in the
first century many reports were written
down
by the companions themselves um
the importance the significance
of these teachings the significance of
these rulings
the fact that the companions themselves
applied these rulings
all these factors um give us
even if even if we're not going to call
certainty let's not call it certainty
um but but to a large degree to a large
degree
rejecting that would be
unrealistic it would be it would be uh
hyper skeptical and and uh it would be
it would be uh
us getting in the way of um
following the religion
to a reasonable degree
but it's not rejection because again
i'm not saying that i'm rejecting it's
more so
[Music]
and again it's just how i see it y'all
are welcome to see it however you want
um but again i don't don't reject it but
the way i see it is like
you have the kudan which is uh it's
absolute
you know right no muslim can disagree on
the quran or
otherwise they're not muslim right you
know that's that's
the main teaching that's the truth right
there in the book
how do you know what's up then
dude do you want to play without you if
you if you want to play that game
you look at the cooldown and start
looking at
all these other religions and how they
all have
very similar some have more pieces of
puzzle than others but then you have the
quran who has the complete
piece of the puzzle and then you have
someone like myself who wasn't a muslim
to begin with
his entire life started doing
self-improvement start getting deeper
into this uh spiritual journey
and i'm over here experiencing things
where i have people telling like oh
this is what's said in the quran like
you're doing exactly what's said in the
quran
and i'm just over here mind-blowing that
i'm experiencing these things i'm
realizing these things
that's already been relaxed it's already
in this book
and then there's other religions that
might have a little piece a little piece
there but then you have this one book as
everything
hasn't been altered in over 1400 years
like that to me that was enough
that gave me like he said
my brother said certainty
and now what i'm saying whatever i'm
saying let me finish what i'm saying bro
let me finish what i'm saying so i see
the quran as being certain where it's
like you know what if you don't follow
what's in this book well you're going
against
the word of god the word of allah
so it's like you know what's going to
happen if you're going against that
there's a straight path you're choosing
to go in a different path so obviously
you know the outcome
i feel like everyone knows the outcome
deep down even if they're not muslim
i mean they have this video side note
they have this video where this song
youtube is the atheist and he was saying
that he's still afraid to help
because he knows deep down he's not on
this straight path there's something
going on here there's there's something
wrong there's a disconnect
but to get back to the thing if someone
is not
following the book they are heading in a
different direction so it's like
that is the word of allah but then
you have the hadith which
are narrations and again like
some may be hyper authentic some may be
a hundred percent
exactly what happened but at the end
allah knows best not us and
i'm not going to rule out that it's
always subject to error like
no matter how respectable no matter how
good of a memory this person had like
no matter how much of a time frame there
was whether it was
a few years 100 years 200 300 years like
allah knows best so it's like i'm not
i'm not rejecting the hadith because
that would be ignorant
and i i do see a lot of people who
reject the hadees
and i don't personally from my own
research i don't see that that is a way
of going but i'm seeing that like
you have the hadees and to me i see it
as like okay
you can choose to follow this and
it may be a hundred percent the truth
you could choose not to follow this and
keep following the quran and
you know at the end allah knows best and
allah will judge you at the end
you know what i'm saying so i was like
i'm not rejecting it but i'm not
i'm not like 100 dead set like you guys
are
yeah i don't think you need to be 100 i
don't think you need to be 100
um and as i was saying the prophet peace
be upon him
ordered specific things um
and and sent representatives and
often it would be like a single
representative
um so one example very famous example is
uh you guys familiar with the the change
of the qibla
so so basically the the muslims prayed
initially um or when they were in medina
they prayed towards uh jerusalem
and uh at one point they actually
shifted
to towards mecca
as a direction of prayer and the prophet
peace be upon him sent
someone to tell the companions
to shift their direction and this
actually happened during their prayer
so they were in prayer and someone runs
in to the mosque
and says hey everyone the prophet said
we're supposed to change our direction
towards mecca
and during prayer they just
turn around now they didn't say
hey we need like we need like 20 people
to say this
one person was enough because the
likelihood
of one person getting that wrong at that
specific time
it's quite low right and it's all about
it religion is all about being
reasonable
and and much of the sharia is about
um again once again in regards to
testimony
um if if there's always a possibility
there's always a possibility of
uh error four people can make a mistake
in
them witnessing an act of adultery
however it's so
unlikely that the ruling is there
the ruling is included there because so
unlikely that the
mistake would occur
now when you say that in my mind i'm
seeing it as
okay at that point the prophet was alive
peace be upon him
so the guy comes in he says yo prophet
just said we gotta pray
this direction it's like okay
no harm no foul i'm a switch i'm gonna
pray in that direction
right officer is still alive i can't go
to the prophet and i can see
like was this clearly something you said
obviously but now now it can't be done
so it's like
it it leaves the choice in the person's
hand where it's like look okay
choose to follow that now and then find
out later
or you could choose not to follow it and
then find out later like at the end of
the day
allah knows best and allah will be the
judge at the end
so you see what i'm saying i do
understand and and i
in my responses we can actually find out
through other eyewitnesses
that's the thing we hear of a report
um let's say whatever it could be
anything let's
let's just stick with that about about
praying in another direction praying
towards makkah
um now that specific report
um and where the odds of someone
else reporting the exact same thing and
how how
what are the odds of both of these
people making a mistake yes he's not
with us anymore
but when we have multiple people
narrating the same thing wouldn't that
suggest that it happens
i would suggest yeah
and and uh again that go it goes back to
the question of how many people do you
need
in order to feel that a matter is
certain
how many people do you feel that
rejecting this number makes it
unreasonable
these are all questions that come to
mind but generally generally
according to the scholars of hadith as
long as you had
one set of reliable
narrators throughout um
that should be sufficient um
of course depending on the strength of
the narrators themselves
that's just that's how just how it was
generally
[Music]
but again um i love what you're saying
i love it and i'm i'm just saying like
it would suggest but at the end of the
day like
let's say i have nine people telling me
one thing
about something that happened yeah and
um
i'm not going to be 100 certain unless
i saw it myself or unless like i could
go to the thing now that's
obviously not feasible it's not going to
happen that's the thing
the thing is you don't need to be
certain
but you ask like what gives you
certainty what amount of people will
give you
sure sure sure so to answer to answer
the question
is like i have this amount of people
it's just
it's going to give me uh whatever
percentage
right percentage might be different for
you for fire for romney for me
but it'll give you some form of
percentage in your mind where you're
like
okay i guess we could see that but
ultimately i have to make the decision
on what i'm going to believe and what
i'm going to carry out there
like am i going to leave those nine
people am i going to carry out
based on what was said or am i going to
[Music]
not believe am i going to pass it up
right you see what i'm saying i i do
understand what you're saying
um at the same time i'm trying to get
across the idea that you don't have to
be certain
in regards to uh following everything
um in in the religion being
relatively certain is sufficient
and that's how you see it um
that's how much of scholarship sees it
if not all of scholarship sees it except
for
a third century
any matijolites um generally
that's just how it was always done
and and again once again it goes back to
the
the example that i mentioned and the
example of the prophet peace be upon him
sending representatives to faraway lands
for example um when when god sent
prophets uh usually he would send you
know
one at a time to a specific uh place
um you know during the time of
um so for example yeah any if i'm not
mistaken
david was a prophet uh on his own
and then it was solomon addison i'm not
sure if
they were prophets at the same time from
what i uh
from my understanding i could be wrong
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna comment on
that further i don't want to be mistaken
but there are there are reports of
prophets being sent
by themselves so so okay one example a
faithless example is jonah
jonah was sent by himself to a group of
people
um one person should be enough if it's a
prophet it's
enough um let alone let alone and this
this prophet is
giving you the full message uh
from god um we should be more
lenient when it comes to a specific
ruling that was mentioned by
that prophet um and and that's how it
was
it was not just seen by scholarship
again that's what the prophet peace be
upon him
uh that's how he saw it and then like
for example uh
when he sent murad to yemen he sent
morad um it wasn't you know
i'm gonna send 10 people with the same
message just to just for everyone to be
certain that this is how i'm saying it
but one person being his representative
was enough a lot of those people from
yemen
never met the prophet peace be upon him
they they never had the chance to
um this was like a year or so before he
passed away or two years or so before he
passed away
um uh when it came to
when it came to hajj when it came to
when it came to
hajj in the ninth year and the prophet
peace be upon him sent a message to
makkah
he sent um
ali to to to uh notify the people of
his message um he sent a bucket as well
if i'm not mistaken
but that means two people two people
were enough
for for his message to get to the people
of makken for that
information to be uh seen as reliable by
him
so generally um if it's good enough for
the prophet peace be upon him then it
should be good enough for us
you good bro yeah yeah i'm good i'm good
yeah trust me i'm good
yeah i think i just the last thing i'll
say
because i feel like this lightning round
turned into like no it's all good
yeah yeah but nothing but love nothing
but love nah enough of ours of course of
course
i think the last thing that i would say
is that actually i'm not even gonna say
because
my mind went blank so i'll take that
i'll take that as a sign let's let's
continue on for real
um i wanted to uh i wanted to ask you
something on hell
it's on the same topic so if you want to
move on leave it no let's keep going
they might bring it back
yeah fair fair enough but it's it's
taking it from a different angle
you said you take the quran right you
accept the quran 100
100 okay so
you believe allah preserved the quran
and and the deen religion right islam
right so when allah
says in the quran that they will not be
true believers until they make you
the prophet saws an example for them or
a judge between them in their matters
right
and when allah says obey allah and the
messenger when allah says take the
prophet
as or take the messenger as an example
how do you as a man in the 21st century
interpret that wouldn't you need
something similar to a hadith
[Music]
you know so that verse one more time
yeah say that say that one more time
yeah so allah says in the quran to take
the prophet
as as an example right and then another
verse allah says that they will not be
true believers until they take you
the prophet or make make the prophet a
judge between them
and allah says in several verses
and obey allah and the messenger right
so three different verses
how would you interpret those as a man
in the 21st century it's along the same
lines of how
do you pray how do you fast how do you
know these things are correct okay
so for me personally when i
read that the quran
is the example the fact that this whole
thing
was said it was transmitted
by this individual like that's the
example
for me but i mean again i'm not
rejecting
the narrations i think the narrations
provide
amazing insight where it can really
really benefit
a muslim in their deen and their way of
life
but again that's that's just me
okay inshallah that that can be the
final note on it then i was just curious
about that yeah
yeah i'm thinking so jessica you you did
thank you brother and you did
allow me to remember what i was gonna
say
so uh brother you said that no one makes
a decision or you can make a decision
without being certain
right like you don't need to have
certainty yes
where it's like for that i would say
that
most people do make decisions
uncertainty
you know they may not be 100 right but
within that moment in time
they make a decision because of the
certainty or at least i speak for myself
um i don't i i don't know
i think most people that took the
vaccine
me included i just got mine yesterday um
did it without certainty i've heard of
people speaking about
really bad side effects but i saw a lot
of people taking it i saw
that not many of them were getting sick
and not many
like facial paralysis cases happening
around me
um for some reason i
i've ended up with doctors as friends
which is something i i
never expected to happen but subhanallah
you know that's not really my crowd
you know but you know i grew up and uh
and all of a sudden i have doctors
around me as friends
and and they're like yeah go for it go
for it you know
you could you could end up dead but you
know the chances of that happening is
really low
so you know i just went with it i just
went i was never certain
let me ask you something why did you get
the vaccine in the first place
because there's a hot there there is a
chance of
there's there's a low chance there's a
low chance of me passing away from
covet i'm not certain
i'm going to pass from passed away from
covet i'm not certain that the
yeah i'm not certain that the vaccine is
going to keep me
safe from it but i felt that there was a
reasonable
um it would be unreasonable to not take
it
yeah and then that's why i took it so
for you the risk
versus the reward like yeah the reward
outweighed the risk
yeah but even though you didn't have
certainty yeah in in the decision in
like oh
i know that i do this and this is gonna
prevent me from having kobe
you had certainty in your analyzation of
the risk and reward
you have certainty that okay well i'm
gonna do this because it would be
ignorant for me not to do it
you know i probably have more risk not
doing it than have
more risk by doing it pretty much pretty
much yeah
okay i'm sure i'm sure this applies to
all of us and everything we do
i've heard that you're training uh to go
to gopro
um and what are are you certain that
you're gonna go pro
oh yeah you are
okay but isn't there isn't there a
chance of getting injured before going
but yeah
big time i've already been injured yeah
and i'm sure you get injured like every
other week right
oh to a degree
okay every like every week every every
like week of
my life of doing some sort of martial
arts i either have like
you know a busted hand a busted leg and
i just like
i'm like i just have to deal with this
like i can't you know prevent
i can't have this prevent me from from
training right now
but michelle i'm glad that you're not
getting you know i'm glad that's not
happening to you
yeah i mean it happens i'm just
you learn from it it's like right okay
that happened
why did that happen okay let's try to
prevent that from happening you know
what i mean
right but i understand what you're
saying yeah
yeah so so um any anything we do from
going to college we go to college we're
not certain that we're going to get that
job
we go to college we're not certain we're
going to get that degree we go you know
we train and we're not sure if we're
definitely going to go pro
the chances of it are quite high however
we will
um we will make these decisions
based on the likelihood of these things
happening
[Music]
yeah and i'm just saying like we're
certain
on the decision at least in that moment
and you know maybe some uncertainty may
come about in there
maybe we don't have certainty that okay
if i train
every single day then i will be
professional
i'm that's not a certainty right because
like you said there's so many factors
that can come into play
but i am certain in my decision that
i am going to train every day to become
pro whether i make it or not
that's that's allah never works you're
not certain that
you training every day will make it to
pro but you're certain that
to make it pro you need to train every
day yes
i'm certain in my decision and that's
what i want to say was like when i came
to islam i was certain
in my decision from my experience
you know i i wouldn't be muslim if i
wasn't certain
oh definitely um i think i think that
that's like something completely
different
um being certain about your religion as
a whole
is different than being certain in
regards to
where to place your hands um after
uh finishing you know for example after
bowing down getting up from bowing if if
you're not certain
whether your hand is supposed to go here
or here
i don't think it's like the biggest
issue in the world i don't believe that
you need to be 100
certain regards to um a smaller matter
like that but definitely when it comes
to something like choosing a religion
but yeah
the lightning run is over guys
let me just let me just let me just
throw in something right there you know
how you said you believe the quran 100
face value you just take it for what it
is yes more
or less don't things in the quran like
the rulings
don't they just resonate with your fitra
what you mean i'll give you an example
you look at society i know what you mean
but what do you mean
i mean if it just resonates with you
don't most of the authentic
hadith hadith just resonate with you
not all of them but a lot of them yes
not
most of the authentic hadith yeah
not all of them but most of them yes
yeah but there are some that
you might not see the wisdom or you
might not fully
like your fitra doesn't just click right
away
if ever i don't know
i don't know like i know with the quran
there was um
there was no disconnect there was no me
like not accepting anything
or not understanding anything like it
clearly resonated because i'm here with
you guys today alhamdulillah
and again i'm not rejecting the hadees
and some may think that i have this
perspective
because there's a hadith that says don't
strike your brother in the face
and then there's rulings that oh well
mma is haram and doing all this is
like look like my my answer and
everything i said today
was like besides that it's just the way
that i see things man and again like i'm
not
trying to create animosity
i'm just telling you guys like look this
is how my mind works
okay that being said you're not a hadith
rejecter
but there are a lot of people that are
hadith rejecters
so freed from your experience
what are some of the main arguments you
hear from people that are
clear hadith rejecters but they claim to
be
muslims they claim to be full believers
in the quran
knowing that the quran says believe
yeah well the most common one is uh
hadiths were written 200 200 years later
uh which again is incorrect um but then
they base that number on uh only the
time in which
he passed away he passed away in the
year 256
something along those lines um and uh
and the thing is we can trace every
single hadith in sahih buhari to an
earlier
narrator it's it's very very easy
to trace reports to um
you know multiple generations before him
um however the focus is on him
because his book is the most famous book
of hadith
that's pretty much it um but that's like
the most
common question that's uh brought up
to be honest um
second would be rejected a lot of
hadith well i i don't see that as a
problem because
that shows that he was someone who is
very skeptical as well
perhaps not as skeptical as angel but he
was quite skeptical
um and and and what i'd like you to
to appreciate is that there was a school
of skepticism
um throughout the first centuries of
islam
much of the filtering was already done
um
and and the thing is you you had experts
in the field
that chucked out a lot of ahadi that
that weren't just problematic i mean
because they sounded problematic
but due to the same issues that you have
um
i mean you know issues with the
reliability of the narrators the
possibility of people forgetting
um but the thing is they would find
evidence they would actually find
evidence
that this narrator made this mistake
here and there
and the thing is um due to
this nud system the system of the chains
of narrators we have the ability
not to just determine the general
message of hadith
but we have the ability to determine the
order of
words and hadiths we have the ability to
to determine
whether a specific word was added onto a
hadith
so for example um one of the most famous
reports is a narration that says the
prophet peace be upon him used to go to
uh uh
a cave and he used to uh yet ahemnath
the word uses yet ahemnath meaning that
he used to worship
uh meaning but
he used to worship means that he used to
um
guys give me give me a synonym for
worship
help me praise praise okay okay
so he used to worship meaning he used to
praise
right and um the scholars of hadith said
this word praise isn't supposed to be
here
this word praise is a commentary by the
narrator
they would catch a single word that was
added onto a hadith and they would say
this is not supposed to be in the actual
report itself
um most one of the most famous reports
is the hadith
of uh jibril in which uh jibril comes to
the prophet peace be upon him and
teaches him about the pillars of islam
and then he mentions you know the
testimony of faith
the prayer um the alms the
fasting of ramavan and the performing of
the pilgrimage uh and a man goes up to
ibn omar
the companion of the prophet peace be
upon him and he said
did you just say the uh
going to the pilgrimage and the fasting
of ramadan
and then eben um said no no no no i said
fasting ramadan and performing the
pilgrimage
so to some of them the order of the
words they were that specific even with
the order of the words they wouldn't
allow
anyone to change that so
that's the thing that's the thing it was
it was a it was a meticulous science it
was very specific
um there was there there was a lot of
effort put into it
and uh it's it's a problem it's a
problem to
um you know shrug a chunk of it off
because of uh skepticism that we have
i think it may i think it's natural to a
degree but the more you get into it the
more you realize that
um it's unjustified let me just tilt my
camera slightly
okay so this right here is
yeah so so this this is
a collection of wikihadith okay and and
his gradings upon them and his reasons
for for creating them weak by the way i
like made a video about it
um today i just never had the chance to
put this back
this isn't supposed to be here
intentionally i mean for this video um
and here is a collection of his
authentic
um the the narrations are great that's
authentic um it's uh 11 volumes
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 volumes and the amount of work that's
put into this
um it's it's it's not normal it's it's
beyond human uh but yeah you had a lot
of people who dedicated their lives
to filtering out uh weakness
from the authentic reports from
filtering out specific
words from filtering out words can you
imagine that
um this cannot be compared to something
like the bible yeah i don't want i'm not
here to attack christianity or anything
like that
um but you know
i mean if we're going to talk about uh a
lack of certainty
um we don't even know who the authors of
the gospels were
you know so there's a lot of work
there's too much work there's something
there's something that gave me
ease which was that there's no cameras
there's no audio recording there's no
way to find out what
the messenger's allowing some said or
did or
thought or felt about different matters
but if there had to be a way
which was the best way to guarantee this
was actually what said
it would be the way things happened yeah
just the way things happen chain of
narration just hadith stronghold um
and it's like assuming things are the
way they are assuming all
of the authentic hadith are in fact true
then it's like there's no better way to
guarantee
than the way things are you are that's
my point
like there's no extra it's not like you
could say oh
they could have done this to get get
more of a guarantee the way things are
are the way they can bring maximum
certainty already
do you know what i mean anything
different might have brought less
and it's this system
this system is something that's unique
to islam by the way this system doesn't
exist elsewhere
uh the amount of information the
biographical data
even enemies of islam admit this even
enemies of islam have said things like
um muslims are really lucky to have set
the system up
and there is no history there is no
history out there
that's well as well preserved uh as
islam
simply due to this system and this
system by the way it's spread
through all islamic sciences um it's not
just specific to a hadith
but even when it came to the commentary
of the quran even when it came to
uh yes you know matters that are
attributed to
to early scholars um
sometimes even when it came to like
stories and anecdotes
uh the is not system um
was utilized everywhere because of how
popular it became
and i wanted to ask you another question
too um and before that
meet me and on how more or less we
we don't listen to music anymore right
it's not in the quran explicitly
you know don't listen to music it's it's
from the hadith that we
attain this wisdom what is your
your outlook on people that want to live
life
focusing on the quran and just looking
at that
i'm not saying they rejected these but
i'm also not saying they
they read them and make an effort to
understand hadith and learn different
ethan
and keep them in their pocket in the
toolkit they just want to live life
saying okay this is the quran this is
what we got
this is all i'm going to live life by
what are the pros and cons of that
okay so uh firstly
um reading a book of like a major
collection of hadith from cover to cover
is not something that anyone's expected
to do
right um i will look into
a specific like me me i personally i'm
stuck you know
researching things that have nothing to
do with me because
of you know garbage i find online
uh you know arguments against islam and
whatnot but
most people don't need to look into that
and
and to me personally um there aren't too
many things that i
uh i need to
research deeply when it comes to hadith
um so for example
um why would i care
about matters that had to do with
inheritance
i'm not interested in learning about
inheritance law
and uh you know a hadith
um yes it's like much of it's in the
quran
um and that's sufficient for me
um but i'm but in regards to the hadith
the reason why i'm not getting into this
i'm an only kid
so it's something that's not a concern
of mine um
how does that have to do with with
livestock and whatnot does that cut
through livestock it's something that
it's not necessarily a concern for most
of us because where
most of us don't raise animals right
you guys raise animals just myself
uh that's pretty good so
learning about that um you know going
through books of hadith in order to
determine how much is that cut you're
supposed to give in regards to animals
that you have it's not something you're
gonna
necessarily look into um
a lot of hadith give us a boost of
spirituality
a lot of our hadith are certainly needed
for our day-to-day
actions for example prayer you know
things have to do with prayer
um but in general
you don't really need to dig too deeply
into
heidi
i hope that uh this is
i got a question i got a question for
you brother
so people who reject
the uh the hadith but they accept the
quran
um a big argument that they'll bring to
the table
is that um the quran
explicitly states that uh
is dictated by allah
yeah right so i agree
now you have these narrations from the
prophet peace be upon him now the one
who brought the word of
allah was the prophet peace be upon him
but you have these narrations that came
after the fact
after the fact that he finished the
cooldown okay now we have a lot of
things that we can get from the hadith
like we see how to pray you know we
wouldn't we wouldn't be
doing the prayers that we do if we
didn't have the hadees
am i right or am i wrong no doubts no
doubt
right so you have these
narrations you have these ideas some
authentic some inauthentic
but then i guess the argument that
they'll bring is that well
now you have scholars basically getting
together
and uh almost voting and making a ruling
as to okay well this is halal
based on a hadith yeah and they have a
problem with that because
in the quran says that allah is the one
that says
what is haram and what is
allah supposedly has already been
decreed in the quran
and then after the fact now you have
these narrations
where it's like prophet peace be upon
him
he may have said this may have said that
no
they they don't know what it is they
don't they don't believe it 100 percent
they're obviously because they're
rejecting the hadees
so they're they're bringing that
argument to say what would you say to
that
same thing with the quran same thing
with the quran you'll find
people differing scholar is differing in
regards to how to
how do we understand quranic verses and
then they will use a specific quranic
verse and and they will extract an
understanding
um that understanding will be based on
their biases they'll be based on their
environment
um while others it will be
an analysis that's free from that and
they would come to a disagreement um
so it's something that would occur with
the quran as well
so would you say that the quran
is the clear-cut answer is is the truth
it's the guidebook
the instruction manual yeah
but at the end of the day the
interpretation is up to the individual
yanni there is i mean i mean there is
clarity
um however
the the interpretation the the false
interpretation will be the fault of the
person who makes the mistake
right um however the quran is clear
uh there are yes there are verses that
are relatively
less clearer than others no doubt about
that
um like there's a very famous example
of of companions
arriving in different understandings
based on
a specific hadith the prophet peace be
upon him um
said basically they were heading out
to uh yeah
yeah you got it you got it bro you got
it
yeah was it uh i think zoho
um when you're on on horseback and
you're
you're going somewhere no oh no i had
something else completely
that's a very good example that me and
angel talked about that um
some of the people were saying to to
pray uh after you get to the destination
other than before that's it that's it
that's it yeah
that's the one so yeah that said so the
prophet said um
don't pray um except
at this destination um
however like asur came and they're like
okay we're supposed to pray
now right or else we're gonna miss it so
let's just
pray now he probably meant you know
let's get there
as soon as possible while the others
took it literally and actually
prayed there so there was this
difference opinion there was a
misunderstanding
and at the end of the day like none of
them were rebuked for
uh their own understanding however there
was
a correct understanding there was a
direct order
so the thing is same with the quran
people will understand verses in
different ways
and there will be a correct answer and
there will be an incorrect answer
however um it's not like
like no one says that this is the uh
the interpreters no one's saying the
interpreter is making that ruling
you know no one is saying that uh the
interpreter
is the one who's legislating this is
that interpreters understanding
at the end of the day
i thought it's been quite for a long
time me
yeah i'm just i'm just listening um one
thing i would add is that um
it's uh it's it's not based on what they
think right there's a science behind it
right uh very clear example in in the
quran itself chapter 3 verse 7 i think i
mentioned this yesterday
that in the quran there are clear verses
and these are the foundation of the book
and other verses are ambiguous those who
look to spread mischief and doubt rely
on the ambiguous
verses in their false interpretations so
we already have this principle
of taking fundamental verses over
ambiguous ones and one example i can
give
is allah uses we in the quran right like
plurality
um is this a royal plurality meaning
allah is is multiple or is this
or sorry is this regular plurality
meaning allah multiple or is this royal
meaning allah is one using the royal
plural like when a king goes up and says
we decided this but he's speaking about
himself
um that's ambiguous there are different
ways of reading that but
when you go to surah al qasas where
allah says
say he is allah the one and only he says
ahad which means like one and only
meaning that
the only way to understand all the other
verses where allah says we
is that he is one using the plural right
this is one method of of
understanding the quran and there's you
know as brother fred mentioned there's a
science behind all of this so it's not
just one person reads one thing and he
says okay well
it says this i think it means that
there's a science behind it
personal personally i i don't think that
we me
you know we could ever mean multiple i
don't i don't consider it to be an
ambiguous term um i feel like it's
it was very clear to everyone who was
listening it's listening to it and uh
um and i'm not aware of any
interpretation that would suggest
otherwise
or or anyone or any scholar who assumed
yeah yeah
the only person who's ever said the only
person who's ever said it means multiple
is like cp
yeah yeah let me be clear then
let me be clear when allah says um like
relating to the verse don't take
ambiguous verses
um yeah they made that ambiguous they
made it ambiguous in the sense that
like in the english language in the
english language they made it ambiguous
as english speakers that
it says we this is the trinity all the
sudden stuff okay
yeah thank you for cleaning that up
that's that that's what i meant
you know what's crazy though is the
christians will look at that and they'll
be like ah
look and the quran is talking about the
trinity but nowhere
in their bible does jesus talk about the
trinity
right right right that's right
ridiculous
was a team man we are closing in on uh
on two hours almost so i'll just wrap it
up
all right thank you so much so much i
learned
about the freaking guys thank you thank
you for being patient with me brother
no no no no no not at all bro i enjoyed
this i enjoyed this
me too i wish i was i wish i was very
prepared yeah
i had no idea you could put me on the
spot like that oh bro i didn't even
i didn't mean to put you on the spot man
like i said it's so good
it's like i usually prepare like for for
something like this i usually prepare
yeah yeah next time next time we'll make
it uh
off the record next time i'll prepare uh
my own lightning round for you guys
yes yes all right
and again bro like don't even don't take
offense to me i wasn't trying to put you
on the spot it's just
i got questions man
i hope you found some of that beneficial
though yes i did
i did i appreciate it i'm glad i'm glad
all right and before we end it off you
said you trained
i did i did muay thai for a bit i did uh
some kickboxing for a bit i did boxing
for a bit
it was it was fun have you done
brazilian jiu jitsu
bro like everyone weighs so much more
than i i weigh so
how much you weigh um 66 kgs
how much is that in pounds let me look
it up
no clue mine 145
oh man you're good bro
bro there's like a guy who who's leg
weight that much and then he was like in
the same class as me and i was like
i just can't do this listen i was doing
a
class the other day and i was rolling
after the class with this guy that
weighs
over 100 pounds more than me and um we
started on our feet
you know try to get the take down listen
there was no takedown this man just
threw his body weight on top
and like i'm over there just trying to
move trying to survive and there was one
point that we started rolling
and then he ended up on side control but
with
with his whole body like his old stomach
on top of my stomach
somewhere like trying to breathe and
then he's like oh so what are you going
to do now i was like well
right now i'm trying to breathe but like
man
you learn real quick how to handle
people who weigh more than you you know
how to handle people who ate less
than you and people who weigh about the
same as you it's a beautiful sport man
right okay i just have bad luck every
time i
i you know i think about it i look into
the room and everyone's like
you know morbidly obese and i'm like
okay so i'm gonna
i'm gonna find something else to do i'm
i'm gonna join the kickboxing class
today
and i just kept on doing that until yeah
so you gotta do it once man you gotta do
it once i i tried i tried a few classes
i enjoyed i enjoyed uh
learning some of it but you know it's
just demotivating
it's just you know like yeah yeah yeah
there's a there's a big learning curve i
think it's like six to 12 months
before you feel like you you kind of
have a grasp on it then it takes like
another year before you're like oh okay
now i know the basics
right right yeah it's not like that with
uh striking we're striking you might be
like a few weeks of course
until next time when we talk about shia
quick little sneak peek but uh we will
air the episode
um that we did with sheikh abdul rahim
mccarthy
on uh you know khabib mma a little bit
of a martial arts it's coming out friday
but for the people watching this they've
already seen it on friday because this
episode is going up on monday okay
yeah but uh thank you so much for
being here taking your time thanks for
having me the truth yeah
refuting these these ja hills uh you do
amazing work
keep doing what you do in the world
if you think if you think this uh this
ep was a crazy because you thought it
was like
putting you on the spot wait till you
see the one
the second one the second one yeah we
started talking about mma me and him got
like
we didn't get eaten but we started like
going back and forth on something do you
guys see that it's the second episode
not the one that comes out day after
tomorrow okay bro it literally
i was there too because rami wasn't
there right now i'm just there sitting
like
bro these two are just i had it
it was nothing but love though it was
nothing but love
that's that's putting that's putting
someone on the spot right that's
right right you died if you thought he
was harsh on you man
oh take it personally at all bro not at
all not at all
it's all it's all a journey it's all
it's all a journey of knowledge jeffy
and we and we try to be transparent like
he's a new reaver you know he has all
these questions
somebody commented uh the other day that
uh i wonder how you guys are off the
camera
and i was like oh you don't have to
wonder just watch our podcast because
we're not fake
how how we are in the podcast is how we
really are when we talk amongst the
three of us
or if we were talking to you without
recording this would be exactly
i'm sure you feel natural there's no
like bit of like okay cool now that
we're done
let's let's see how we let's talk how we
really are
you know maybe we'll be a little more
mindful about topics and
words that might get demonetized right
that's it right
because if we weren't if we weren't
natural then
we would have reached out to him like
hey we're going to ask you this this and
that
go ahead and have that ready i'm going
to put you on the spot
that's great man that's great usually
i'm going to be frank
usually some of the streams that i've
had
as soon as we shut off that camera all
the fun
all the fun starts you know i'm getting
frank here you know
i'm glad i'm glad you guys keeping it
real yeah we try
but i understand what you mean man
because like it's weird too when you
when you're streaming when you're
recording like yeah you want to be
yourself
you want to be natural but it's like you
have all this audience
where it's like a part of you
subconsciously is going to be holding
back and
you know i'm not here to say that all of
us are not holding back
but we try our best to just be as real
as possible
as natural and candid as we can be
you know but i know what you mean man
again we appreciate you being here thank
you we appreciate you being here
and arami go ahead and run it off end
off this beautiful episode man
one of the the least structured ones
one of the most fun ones i had for sure
i think
yeah 100 yes you must be happy
uh if you made it this far into the
episode what should they comment
hashtag lightning hashtag lightning
lightning round all right if you made it
this fun episode remember to comment
hashtag
lightning round may allah bless you
brother fareed and uh the other two
brothers on this podcast
bless you all for watching we hope this
has been immensely beneficial for
everyone
you know you can do this without school
you already know that you can bring in
money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life for
you to go to college
so you can get this degree and make this
money whereas bro
i keep preaching this you don't need
school if you don't need school
if you're not trying to be a doctor
you're not trying to be a lawyer you're
not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer
right not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you could do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in ariba in interest in student
loans
i grew up in america i was actually born
in the amethyah
uh or the gaddiani and the headquarters
their old headquarters in
pakistan it was pretty rough you know
and i saw hustlers and pimps and
prostitutes
on the street so i i knew about the
hustle i knew who was hustling who and
why they were hustling and in ahmediyya
i saw
it i didn't see genuine people i saw
you know i saw people who were who were
hiding something i thought
growing up ah and islam was close
it was a closer it's you know we were
this is far
away i ended up losing my job my my
brother he ends up spying on my computer
he ends up he ends up hiring uh amity's
in this
company which is like discriminate
hiring discrimination against the law
and they start spying on my computer and
i'm like the vice president of the
company
and i got these guys spying on my
computer
they go back and tell him hey your
brother's reading and
uh am the awareness websites he's going
and seeing what ahmadiyya is about and
he doesn't go to the mosque he doesn't
give us any money from germany
usa canada and the uk they're bringing
in 100 million a year
and they have about 300 million in
assets
land property buildings where the halifa
lives
in the uk it's a 50 million dollar
facility
where he lives right in pounds i think
it's like 39 million pounds or something
like that
and we caught them storing money
overseas in panama
and their moms are all doing well
so they get the majority of the money
because i found it on the on the balance
sheet
the uh um the amne murugbees
get are living good and they're
uh you can call them the shareholders so
it's the mirza family
and their group of murabis and their
kids are
are super dedicated to the jamaat and
they
they get other people to give money it
started under british colonialism
and uh um in british india and
anywhere the british word um the other
hot spot was egypt and the suez canal
and the british needed that suez canal
so you'll see some of the islamic
scholars saying similar things to what
musical arm mammoth was saying
like they were all saying that islam is
dead in
egypt a few of them were started to pop
up so it's a total british
agenda my dad's got the small business
instead of us growing our small business
all the profit my dad's giving up
we work seven days a week our our house
leaks
um it's terrible since i was seven from
age seven to eighteen i worked seven
days a week with my dad
never missed the day never got a day off
he never gave me a nickel i said okay
bro i i can't keep quiet
anymore this is out of control on top of
that they're robbing my family
for the mon you know on the financial
aspect
the time and then they got these other
conventions you got to go to
and all the kids are like cutting school
we're all
we're all hanging out in the parking lot
we don't want to listen to these
speeches you know drop the charade
brother
come to islam it's so much easy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm